du changement à venir peut-être dans le
cadre de la formation professionnelle
dans les écoles au collège au lycée des
zeks de changements présentés hier par
jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale on
en parle ce matin dans son caddie avec
vous ce aller théodore bonjour oui
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en tant
que membre du syndicat idf au
indépendance et direction et le syndicat
indépendant des personnels de direction
de l'éducation nationale le ministre son
ambition c'est de revaloriser cette voie
professionnelle à l'école première
question il était temps il était temps
oui il était temps puisque nous savons
si la dernière réforme date de du temps
puisque la réforme de 2010 on avait
résisté un petit peu le positionnement
de l'enseignement professionnel dans le
système il était temps parce que on a
des entreprises qui évoluent on a des
métiers qui évolue on a des systèmes qui
évolue note qu'il faut il faut
équilibrer tout ça donc nous sommes en
attente évidemment mais nous sommes
aussi
curieux de savoir comment on va mettre
tous à pouvoir répondre à l'objectif
premier qui est de former et de
permettre aux jeunes de s'insérer
facilement ce le marché de l'emploi ni
en bague équipe à cachan j'en ai
théodore ces mauvais réputation que voie
professionnelle thani malheureusement à
l'aumône alors pendant longtemps ça a
été ça je crois que le travail doit être
fait par nous c'est vrai que nous qui
sommes professionnels et moi qui suis
sous le terrain puisque je suis
effectivement membre d'un syndicat
je rappelais le syndicat majoritaire
dpsd direction mais je suis aussi
proviseur d'un lycée professionnel et
tout les jours je voit évoluer mes
élèves et je crois parfois c'est un
mauvais procès qui est fait à
l'enseignement professionnel parce que
nous avons de plus en plus beaucoup
d'intelligence au sein de nos
établissements et beaucoup beaucoup
d'élèves qui réussissent alors si vous
êtes si on a on a beaucoup de beaucoup
d'élèves qui sont fragiles sur le plan
économique sur le plan social mais on a
beaucoup d'intelligence et puis ce
cliché de dire que cette filière
professionnelle n'accueille que des
enfants des milieux défavorisés
c'est pas un cliché c'est vrai que
statistiquement on voit que nous
regroupons l'ensembledes beaucoup
d'élèves qui sont en difficultés
sociales et économiques
mais c'est pas parce qu'on est en
difficulté soutien à l'économie il faut
forcément dit qu'il n'y a pas de la
réussite il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas un parent ou d'excellence
il ya des élèves qui partent du lycée
professionnel et puis qui sont par la
suite ingénieurs j'avais j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir de travailler quand
je suis entré dans le métier il y avait
un inspecteur
académique qui était qui avait un bep
qui a commencé par un bep
oui alors trois axes trois axes ont été
annoncés insérer des lycées
professionnels au sein de campus ou de
réseaux deuxième axe revoir la liste des
bacs pros rendent leurs intitulés plus
compréhensible bien fait remaniée les
trois années du 10 ans va commencer par
cette première idée la création de
véritables campus professionnel en
martinique est à peu près dix lycéens
professionnels
alors c'est bon c'est pas bon cette idée
de campus et qu'est ce qu'on peut
entendre partent en bus alors qu'en plus
des meetings en plus professionnel vous
avez désir est plutôt qu'en plus de
michele hider il me semble c'est de
travailler en réseau alors je ne suis
pas là pour défendre uni pour décrier
l'idée pour moi c'est de se positionner
et de voir comment ça peut répondre à un
objectif qui est de mieux permettre aux
jeunes d'acquérir des compétences
je crois que tu as un tout petit
territoire l'idée de réseau parce que
derrière l'idée de campus de métier
c'est ça c'est de mettre en réseau un
certain nombre d'établissements et des
entreprises et la collectivité et l'état
représenté par le toit et nous nous
sommes un vecteur de l'état en tant que
chef d'établissement
je pense que sur un tout petit
territoire on peut pas s'isoler et créer
des modèles des systèmes chacun dans son
coin donc eu l'idée de campus je crois
c'est une bonne forme
maintenant cela n'y aura attendu jean
michel blanquer on essaie de le faire
maintenant on n'a pas de carte des
métiers de plans de formation sur
plusieurs années d'écouté des chefs
d'entreprise pour établir quelles sont
les formations à mettre sur prier pour
répondre aux besoins de notre martinique
non mais on n'a pas entendu mais je
crois qu'il faut organiser donc si nous
avons un ministre il décide d'organiser
les choses à nous aussi d'être là pour
faire un certain nombre de propositions
parce que c'est ça en tous les cas en
tous les cas le syndicat que je
représente on n'a pas dit que toutes les
intelligences sont forcément regroupés
chez nous au niveau de notre syndicat
on a des choses à dire puisque nous
sommes aussi professionnels nous sommes
sous le tir est donc on a envie de peser
sur les décisions qui vont être prises
ouais les professionnels vont écouter
cela les politiques vont écouter cela on
le dit très clairement les régions les
régions devront participer à ce campus
oui les régions devront participer est
ce que les époux visionner politiques
vont écouter en tous les cas les
politiques
finales doivent écouter puisque nous
sommes tous là on a comme le seul
objectif c'est mieux former nos enfants
oui alors vous êtes proviseur ou la vie
dit du ces professionnels de
chateauboeuf combien d'informations chez
vous on a on à la filière 5 c'est qu'on
va dire filière on a à peu près 150
élèves on va du ca paix jusqu'au bts
donc dont vous êtes très bien placé pour
dire qu'effectivement il ya un mort
peut-être de lisibilité sur les
formations sous l'intitulé des
formations qu'on propose aux élèves et
ils amènent le ministre veut
manifestement un maître yoda à tout cela
alors je ne sais pas si elle manque de
visibilité je pense que peut-être que il
peut y avoir certains moments un
décalage entre la sortie d'une promotion
formés et la réalité je dirais du monde
économique des entreprises 80 bac
professionnel quand même ça alors qu'à
80 la voilà à l'échelle de la france
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas chez
nous et puis après la difficulté c'est
toujours si vous voulez là l'ambition
individuelle qui est de préparer un
diplôme et puis vous avez toujours si
vous voulez le schéma collectif qui
parfois permet on ne permet pas est ce
que la martinique peut tout faire
ça c'est la grande question est ce qu'on
a aussi retiré les jambes richer a eu à
des choix fera des choix affectif qui
décide qui c'est en écoutant le tissu
économique
c'est en regardant en appliquant ce que
décident les politiques comment ça se
passe c'est en écoutant le tissu
économique c'est le travail que nous
faisons que nous faisons sur place si on
faisait les remontées d'informations
si le travail que fait le centre
d'orientation c'est le travail que font
je dirais toutes les instances qui
concerne le délai la formation des
jeunes et puis après une décision est
prise au niveau de l'état représenté par
le rectorat avec l'appui du politique
allez théodore est aujourd'hui en 2018
nous savons quels seront les besoins de
la martinique en termes de formation
professionnelle à l objectif et 2030
honnêtement difficile honnêtement
difficile c'est compliqué de dire
de prévoir mais on peut on peut quand
même voit qu'il ya quelques quelques
tendances
bon tout la sécurité c'est sûr qu'on
bientôt dans tous les secteurs du
numérique qu'on le veuille ou non ça
m'ennuie dans tous les sens samedi dans
tous les territoires
donc j'ai dû à l'amérique c'est sûr que
ce sera la dent d'ici 2030 mais on peut
avoir une visibilité par exemple sur les
demandes de la boucherie de
l'agriculture d'offres mettant sur super
nous prenons la boucherie l'agriculture
si vous voulez ce soit des diplômes qui
forment sur deux ans s'ils sont assez ap
sur trois ans ou un bac pro donc la
lisibilité c'est de rendre l'équilibré
entre la formation et les demandes des
professionnels et je crois que les
chambres qui regroupe les professionnels
doivent être associés à ces mesures pour
nous permettre de prendre les meilleurs
les meilleures décisions
cette réforme que compte faire votre
syndicat vous allez faire remonter une
petite note à monsieur blanc qui a pu
lui dire telle chose oui telle chose non
c'est pas comme ça que nous possédons
toutes façons le national s'est
positionné par rapport
je dirais aux discours et par rapport
aux mesures nous ce que nous voulons
localement c'est de voir comment ça va
se mettre en place de manière concrète
et nous voulons être associés aux
différentes mesures mais quand vous
regardez les 12 mois pas les passer en
revue tous les douze les 12 points mais
on voit qu'il ya des choses qui nous
laisse
un exemple écouter quand on parle de
conflits campus d'excellence qui serait
content
les campus d'excellence quand on nous
dit appel au projet pia pia 3 qui est de
cinquante mille 50 millions d'euros que
le ministre pense investir nous on a
envie de 10 au niveau de la martinique
nous on sera concernée par trouille et
donc on va être vigilant vous êtes
associé à ça donc il ya des milliers des
mesures qu'il faut voir et puis je vous
ai dit est le diable est dans le détail
il faut aller voir comment les choses
vont se remet nous mettre donc voilà
mais dans tout cela
finalement ce qui est le plus important
c'est qu'on parle de cette formation
professionnelle l'image de marque sera
au rhénus y aura un impact plus positif
c'est peut-être ça l'essentiel
oui oui je pense que déjà il ya un
certain nombre de mes yeux qu'on peut
saluer qui est de plus au regard des
indicateurs
je dirais du passage du nombre d'élèves
en lycée général et technologique comme
l'indicateur phare mais aussi de
regarder les élèves qui vont vers le
lycée professionnel donc c'est un moyen
de donner du sens au parcours
d'excellence dans le dossier au niveau
du lycée pour qui ce n'était pas encore
le cas
ce n'était pas exactement le cas il y
avait quand même cette petite
concurrence entre vouloir et
obligatoirement que les élèves les
meilleures tous les cas à et vers le
lycée général et technologique et
réserver les élèves plus fragiles pour
nous maintenant dans ce nouveau contexte
il me semble on aura des élèves aussi
qui seront intéressés pour définir moi
j'ai une filière gemmois qu'ils étaient
mauvais il ya deux ans qui est le
système si tu aimes nuit quand on
regarde ce qui est demandé vous avez
besoin aussi des élèves qui sont je
dirais solide
ouais injustement ce chef d'entreprise
puisqu'on les a évoqué tout à l'heure
quel regard izon sur ces élèves qui
viennent des lycées professionnels
auxquels ils peuvent accorder allez un
peu de leur temps dans les entreprises
pour les accueillir et sait comment il
les voit ses élèves alors évidemment
nous attendons toujours plus les chefs
d'entreprise quand je dis ça c'est que
nous savons que nous sommes associés
qu'on le veuille ou non lycée
professionnel nous élève doit partir en
formation pendant 22 semaines et il
arrive tout au moins à avoir des
périodes de stage je crois que même chez
vous il ya eu des élèves qui sont venus
quand vous avez accepté non on voit très
bien que le club allemand je dirai au
niveau de la martinique
les chefs d'entreprises jouent le jeu
alors c'est vrai peut-être que j'ai un
regard très personnel puisque en ce
moment
je suis en train de travailler avec
beaucoup de chefs d'états de
l'entreprise et beaucoup se déplace et
encore vendredi encore on avait le
président de carrefour celui que
responsable de carrefour martin qui
était chez nous pour parler de 25 élèves
donc voyez les les chefs d'entreprise se
déplace donc peut-être que je suis mal
placé pour le dire mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une tendance quand
même à nous écouter
ils ont peut-être que les choses ne sont
pas il faudra revoir c'est 1 de chance
pour être plus performants nous nous
voulons toujours plus mais un effort
quelques pas qui est fait de plus en
plus on a parlé de ces filières
professionnelles comme étant le
principal avait comme principale cible
li lé des élèves de milieux défavorisés
est ce que en dehors de cette formation
que vous leur donnez au jour le jour
est-ce qu'il faut leur dire également
qu'il ya une attitude comportement une
façon de s'habiller
une fois qu'on sort de l'école puisque
vous avez d'uniforme mais lorsqu'on
arrive en entreprise il ya peut-être des
codes à respecter est ce qu'ils en ont
conscience
alors moi je crois que ce sont des
élèves effectivement pourquoi je vous ai
dit qu'ils sont fragiles économiquement
socialement
donc ils n'ont pas tous les codes ça
c'est sûr donc je crois que tout le
monde on est dans un ensemble où tout le
monde doit jouer son rôle dans son dos à
sa place chacun à sa place c'est vrai
mais on a tous quelque chose à dire je
crois qu'on peut pas regarder
l'établissement scolaire comme le seul
le seul endroit le seul lieu où on peut
parler de tenues vestimentaires de
comportement de savoir être savoir faire
l'entreprise aussi doit jouer son rôle
c'est au patron de dire que je sais que
quand tu es dans l'établissement
scolaire
tu respecte les codes chez moi tu dois
respecter le pote et c'est un travail
collectif qu'on doit faire
nous sommes étaient appelés
effectivement par des chefs d'entreprise
qui nous dit que les comportements sont
sont parfois limite mais je vous dirais
que statistiquement nous ont beaucoup
plus de plus en plus d un peu les
pouvoirs que souvent ça se passe mieux
en entreprise que chez nous en
établissement scolaire voilà merci
d'avoir tu ce lot avec toi l'intérieur
rappelle que vous êtes membre du
syndicat idf et que vous étiez là pour
nous parler de ses axes de la réforme
sur l'enseignement professionnel à
l'école merci d'avoir été avec nous dans
son caddie bonne journée merci à vous
roy
[Musique]